all right so um so welcome to another
edition of romantic games so first game
we're gonna take a look at by one of the
viewers requests you know we're gonna
took a look at take a look at one of
Mac's
Oilers games and this is like one of the
most interesting games that I found
which he wanted which was kind of you
know it wasn't like technical or
romantic because it was 1950s but it was
romantic in the chest style and in a
complications or foul it's actually you
can also read more about it in the
candidates Zurich book it's from 1953 so
the analysis are actually from there
but anyway so it was a fun game so you
know hopefully you guys enjoy so it's uh
Kings Indian defense neither played as
you guys know neither was you know
Miguel Miguel neither was the first
inventor of the famous Schneider defense
in a Sicilian defense so black played e5
which leads to a very sharp line now see
v e5 whenever we see both pawns pushed
like that it's usually leads to very
double-edged struggle so objectively
speaking I think a white should play
something like e 492 Castle play with a
simple space advantage and hopefully go
for long squeeze but again this would
not be such a fun game if white would
play like this usually in order for the
game to be you know a Jew like a jewel
it needs to be something a little bit
creative in the beginning so here we are
Bishop g5 first going for this pin
giving up the bishop pair and following
up okay so if d6 his idea was to go
Queen d2 and did the spin is very
unpleasant
so black goes for h6 and now white went
for a very double-edged but very
creative option 26 and this was probably
done in conjunction with Bishop g5 this
was kind of connected with each other
because the idea of that is that now
black is shutting down the bishop and
black will have a hard time harder time
getting all his development in however
that move is very risky pawn on d6 and
according to the computer the computer
doesn't really approve because the
computer can defend everything but from
practical standpoint of view it's it was
a very strong idea so black played
knight c6 III b6 and now white played a
very nice move Bishop g5 no way back
King h8 okay that that move was to free
the spawn once the Queen moves so that
one can like get rid of that knight on
e4 so 94 Queens e8 however a white
continues his initiative play h4 there
is no retreating when we're attacking
right we need to continue playing very
energetically f5 Knight g5 so white is
threatening knight of seven so what does
black do he doesn't care he goes Bishop
e7 completes his development so now what
should Y do should he execute well if he
does this then after this and followed
by Queen f6 and e4 black would have tons
of compensation for the exchange and it
would be black who's much better
black would have the initiative so why
did not go this far just to be end up
having to be on the defensive side after
all that so what does why do adds more
fuel to the fire with the move g4 and
really adding you know more attackers
into that King and trying to really bust
open that already shivery King efore
I think at some point there was a room
of rugby 8 which might have been a
better option just to try to trade off
this Bishop afford though is a very
logical of opening up this bishop but he
does allow this knight control over
there Foursquare so the move was
double-edged maybe it was not the best
practical decision by black so white
plays 92 of course who cares about
opponent bitsu in a complicated position
like this that bone is meaningless
bishop xb2 knight of four and now as we
could see white has three pieces
attacking and also pawns potentially
could play a big part of it as well so
black is ready it's very dangerous for
black for example if he takes on a1 then
what do you guys think white should do
that how should white try to execute an
attack in the best way
yes Ashish
kingi seven
all the ladies
the best move is 96 was correct but here
GTX of 5 it was probably the best move
because again it's not about the
material it's all about that kink if we
take the rook you know we're gonna get
checked and then like Queen takes f8 and
then we lose most of our attack attack
loses steam if we do this then also I
mean move like Queen f6 will you know
kind of four starts to trade Queens so
again we have to if we're gonna play
like this we have to continue playing
energetical it takes and after this king
of one let's say if this you have queen
h5 and the lines are very complicated
but black is in very very big danger
black has to play super precise will
adjust not to lose right away I think
objectively position is roughly equal
but from practical standpoint of view I
would say white is almost winged so
that's why black played Queen of six
combining attack and defense threatening
respects of one a one again like really
winning the rook and defending g6 so now
what white should do okay it takes
natural so now black could instead of
taking on a one could do G takes a five
maybe that was a better practical
decision in which case white might play
something like this this Knight g6 here
rook g1 and the game is still very messy
again if you want even more details
there is the surah book the analysis is
all in there but here I don't want to
flood you with too much analysis I just
want to show you the beautiful game so
in the game which takes a 1 was played
again it's not about how sound it is
romantic games are very often as I
mentioned before not completely sound
Knight 66 King g7 964
and it looks like Black's fine because
night 63
there's Queen takes of two but just
simple night of four and this is a
retreating move but it sets up new
forces the rukon g1 and it sets up at
sets of white for you know for a
potential regrouping that puts black
into more trouble so for example black
played King h8 which allows white to
recoup the material and now white is
only down in exchange with still very
powerful compensation but what will what
would Y do if Bishop e5 will have Bishop
e5 then Knight c3 and then where does
the Queen go the queen is almost trapped
only move to not get forked or lose the
queen is queen h7 but then queen g4
followed by Knight g6 and white is
winning same thing happens after this
and then black will either get made it
or get forked
so King h8 was played and now white was
able to at least recoup the bishop you
know very important bishop because that
bishop was attacking and defending so
now let's take stock very quickly white
is down in exchange for one point but
white still has a lot of compensation a
lot of attacks so we can definitely say
White's play worked or okie eight now
what should do I do the night lost at
sea Foursquare so what does white do
nights coming to g3 anyway three to
another path he finds so really getting
to the heart of blacks position rubgy
eight may be an idea it was a little bit
more tenacious here rook g8 was played
yeah
with room to one half work that's a good
question I think I can probably play
rook up six
but yeah it was a certainly an
interesting option definitely something
to consider but looks like 92 is harder
to defend against so Russia 8 so the
idea is maybe there was also bish basics
instead of 98 bish basics trying to go
95 at some point he needed to get at
night into defense he played rugby 8 h5
so if he takes again that would be black
would be very happy now this Bishop is
on a post the knight can move suddenly
black has very good play so again we
shouldn't get greedy that Bishop is
worth a look h5 we want to go here and
keep that Bishop monsterous Bishop now
Knight g3 so if now the Queen has no
we're good to go
so he had to take if here you probably
go 94 so rook takes G 3 after you see
tree root X III king of - and now
material is equal but White's piece
placement that's much better
and that's why white is winning in this
position rook e8 and now white played
another I think very nice move again
Queen a1 looks tempting but doesn't do
much King h7 so what does y do
he trades off black's most active rook
most active piece broken e8 because the
rookin e8 controls a lot of piece a lot
of key squares it's one of life's most
active pieces and the rook on h1 is the
one piece that doesn't do anything
anymore
once the pawns on h5 so therefore white
trades are rokoff and tries to weaken
blacks back rank so black took white
took
if he moves the Rockaway I think then in
an hour white truck is even more
powerful now you can play move like
Queen a one probably or even King G -
threatening 96 here I think white is
just having very powerful initiative so
then it's clear if you have to move back
away then it's clear that it's an
White's favor
so black took and now in this position
if black plays 95 you have to still be
careful you can't play here because of
93 but you have to do Queen to xt5 Queen
65 96 so King g7 Queen comes in
and now a nice finishing touch now the
night is also good for defensive
purposes and now the Queen and the
bishop and the pawn take care of the
rest
so black played here at least to defend
e7
and black resigned because after context
h5 there's not a four or Bishop f7 yeah
so this was one of these over immortals
I shall say this is one of these
beautiful games by Ava that I've noticed
but maybe there are some other jewels
that I haven't noticed but this one is I
think very famous one all right now that
we did a navel Avery game let's take a
look at some of the older classics
because after all they would fit more
for the you know Romantic era so let's
look at the game between stainless and
Lasker
from their World Championship match from
818 no actually it's not from
championship match it's London
International it was a radio after
Lasker was a world champion and stadiums
was already quite old I mean he was like
you know at the end of his career
definitely but still you know it was a
very interesting game if 45 Knight c3
Knight f6 this is called the Vienna D 5
D 3 and in this position the most common
move is a e6 of 4 but in the game he
played knight c6
and here I think if five is kind of okay
for white but as you know sometimes
again in order to create an immortal
classic there has to be a little bit
inaccuracies in the beginning okay all
these moves are pretty natural here
white should probably just Castle
kingside
and now it's black who is getting pieces
into the game of course black does not
trade that off because that would help
the white bishop get in the game so
Bishop d7 95
who can tell us how should black now
continue the attack White's plan is
clear he is attacking the pawn and he
also wants to go Bishop of three
stainless thinks he has everything in
control but in fact it's not so position
is very dangerous for for white
so how should black play here
a sheesh
naj for very good and also type Jitsu so
Mishra three then you know we can all of
course just take that but still that
might have been a better option but
white but Knight of three
all right so knight of three is kind of
a silent draw for do we take it no of
course not
how should black continue his attack
you've seen this game okay let's let's
give someone else a chance
rook takes it to Quinn Texas ooh um yeah
well again you can do that but that only
I think gets back the exchange but I
mean where's your attack just gonna be
some normal position right so yeah it's
certainly possible
you know continuation it's not a blunder
but you know when you see a war line you
like let's look for something better
even though this certainly is a
candidate idea but let's look for
something even better good try though
addy
- wedge - King takes
kim jiwon
yeah but again that line I mean I think
there has quite a few I mean I can take
on h4 right I can do rook F - I mean
it's you're kind of hoping a little bit
for like one line to work but again you
know yeah yeah I mean the idea is
similar but it's you don't want to give
away too many pieces Bishop h3 I think I
can take or even I can take the this one
Bishop g3
I think I'd take here yeah but okay I
can do this
you know it's I can do Bishop g4 check
like I have many options to be okay here
right it's in general whenever you go
for a complicated line that you want to
sacrifice at it's important to keep in
mind that you have to consider like how
many options he has to realistically
defend right if they're like many ways
that you can be potentially fine then
it's not as likely to work right you
want to make sure when you go for a line
that he doesn't have too many options to
like you know defend and very easily
right you want to make sure he doesn't
have a easy defense at least that in
every line you're having a very
promising attack that's the idea
not just like putting all your eggs in
one basket hoping like one line somehow
works out when they're like three lines
that might not go in our favor no we
didn't that is the correct move here
Knight xg2 yes because after King takes
g2 [ __ ] takes h3 exclaim follow-up and
now yeah we cannot do this anymore
because this would lead to an
unstoppable attack king of two is made
and after this there's a rook lift
coming then rook h4 and then we get rid
of the knight and then we made so it's a
forced mate basically in a few moves
there's also Ruby g4 and then you know
Russia for drew catch were just too many
ideas for for black so this is winning
so therefore white had nothing better
than to go king of two but now we
already know that black has a very
promising initiative because you know I
mean you have two points for the piece
and you could even recoup materials so
you're not gonna be download cereal but
it's like it's good enough to calculate
the line with this where you're at least
making a draw but you're pretty sure
that you're even winning but also to
know that if he doesn't take that at the
very least you're gonna be doing quite
well but now let's try to find the best
way
you continue the attack do we take the
route kind of wanders there's something
better for black oh hello snacks
so who can tell us how should we follow
up on the attack for black
yadi
um yeah this page too is interesting if
he takes but chess is not checkers right
we don't have to take what are you
threatening like what if I play like
rook h1 let's say
yeah I mean it's too slow again it's a
very important to anticipate your
opponent's best ideas right don't just
assume he'll just let you get like all
these free moves right it's important to
anticipate opponent's best defenses okay
good try though any other idea the
bishop on these six is already good
right we don't need to touch it we need
to improve the pieces that are not yet
playing and sometimes as well a fall or
heavy pieces are playing we need to find
another way
do you remember putting on a spot here a
little bit you're close it was g5g for
but I think if you go right away then
we're taking it so that's why just
prepared with f6 yeah I mean you can
actually do a very slow move but the
point is that this g5 g4 is just a very
powerful idea and white cannot do much I
mean again you know you could afford to
play a little bit slowly because you're
not down that much material right you're
down a piece for two points so that
means you could kind of afford to play a
little bit slower and still you know how
very promising initiative but this is
what my first ever coach we used to
describe as a fifth strength so in other
words you know we have already like the
Queen rook bishops you know the major
the major attacking pieces in the game
but sometimes that's not quite enough in
like we need a little porn to really you
know do the final have the final say you
know do a little last you know
disturbing of harmony to really make the
attack sort of complete you know many in
many attacks you see the porn has the
final say and that's actually very
instructive in a lot of ways so even
better than you know [ __ ] takes of one
because after Ruchi one it's already
very hard for a white to defend g5 I
mean I guess you could have tried rook
h1 but but then I think you could
probably play Queen h5 and then if the
knight moves you have Queen h4 and still
this is a threat
and still I don't see a good way to
defend although maybe there is Bishop f1
yeah I don't know maybe he should have
tried yeah maybe he should have tried
that one maybe that was a little better
try yeah maybe queen of five is best in
that case yeah Queen of five probably in
that case is best so and then g5g for
and after this you know maybe all right
then then you can do this I think yeah
yeah then you can do this and if you
asked about King G one then oh well well
wait yeah you can probably just go Queen
Chi for anyway threatening this sent so
black still has a very strong attack as
he saw with the evaluation is like minus
2 or something so well black is still
you know but maybe that was a better try
Rock h1 he played here he decided to
give up he give back the piece but now
black is just the materially equal but
has all his open files and you know why
it's not really long for this game
Quincy three bush before Rock h1 giving
up the exchange I mean what else
otherwise Bishop III is coming you know
so rock h1
and eventually white tried some
complications but it didn't really work
you know trying to take the night and
now that he will lose the night as well
he will be down a rook and still being
attacked white threw in the towel here
alright guys any questions so far all
right
no questions one will continue let's go
over now a game which is the Evergreen
game and this is a game you guys might
have seen before
but I was told nobody here showed this
game before so we'll go over it it's a
really true romantic game Anderson
against your friends de fresney Jean
1852
so here's a thousand Evans gambit is
started with an Evans gambit so white
played in the spirit of the gambit
sacrifice the spawns for development d3
Queen b3 attacking of seven Queen f6 be
five Queen g6 rookie 197 Bishop e3 b5
Quint XB v ro b8 queen f4 this should be
692 Nightbeat might be d2 this should be
794 so so far both sides are playing
pretty logically right white is getting
his pieces in the game black is also
defending pretty successfully queen of
five which takes d3 queen h5 and here
was the kind of a critical moment of the
game here
you know Anderson went for a spectacular
move not completely sound but it became
very good in the game because I created
an immortal as a result right so white
went for this move Knight of 6
which the e6 on IDs well 96 I think we
can just take that probably and yeah and
you can Castle okay I mean it's also
pretty promising now what do you guys
think is the best move for white first
of all who can tell us what the best
move might be in this position no Knight
of six is technically a mistake
interestingly enough but it created an
immortal
yeah
yeah 93 was better yes Coogan h6 Bishop
c1 cooing here and then you know
something like this and something like
this and white would win like in a
routine way but of course as Kasparov
says then chess would have lost one of
the jewels from its crown so you know
Knight of six was played G f ef Andrew G
8 good move counter-attacking and now
rook Jiwon was played all right
and now question to you guys a little
bit of a challenge find the best defense
for black here
protects you - King takes Jitsu no it's
quintics cheap or it's controlled yeah I
mean ideas good though it's if only you
can somehow O'Quinn decks of three was
played in the game and that allowed
whites who went beautifully
so Ashish 94 aren't you getting made at
what rook takes is seven
yeah no I mean you're getting made of
them
95 rook takes e5 yeah I'm not sure
optics of one king of one yeah rookie 95
maybe it's interesting I don't know well
I think there's a simpler way yes I did
Bishop g4 this should be 4 I don't know
I mean not I don't know if you have a
big threat here I mean maybe I can even
play move like this I don't know what's
let's ask the engine just in case there
should be 4 yeah but surety for would be
yeah but should be 4 is not too bad
like leads to equal position what else
did you say
who else suggested I move so Bishop g4
was suggested and you know 94 doesn't
work yet some 819 only a 1995 right 95
95 rook takes d5 real takes jitsu king
of 1 takes King e1 yeah that doesn't
work
yeah so the best move was routed well
maybe not the best move but one of the
moves was Luke g4 and that would have
actually shut down but actually Eddie
your your your move computer likes more
so you actually found a better move here
then then Kasparov you know the engine
is giving 0-0 after Bishop g4 and after
route g4 it sounds like this should be
for white is a little bit better I mean
anyway it's complicated but long story
short black could've defended but still
white is actually not worse but Bishop
g4 is actually very creative move and
indeed it's very good you know you're
setting up Queen f3 but you're getting
rid of the coordination so add a good
job you know very nice there should be
four very nice move
but you took enough three so who can
tell us who can tell us why was this a
mistake and I'll try to find the
beautiful combination for white which
made this game one of the most famous
games ever
yeah go ahead
yes rookie 797 now I mean other moves
also loose but I mean right now there's
no point of going over them I mean
there's also Kasparov spooks which cover
that but Knight 67 Kings here should
have five if King c6 Bishop d7 is made
and and then it's beautiful called the
Evergreen game don't know exactly why
it's called like that but you can google
and find out okay here's another game
this time it's a game that under Sun
lost to morphine another one of these
romantic ones
so this was a king's game but also in
spirit of romantic
so if 95 then we have this so a six and
now here we go Knight takes d5
exclamation mark
now white is up a porn still with a nice
attack
Knight takes b7 Queen takes b7 and now a
five all right
what should white play
oh I don't know it's
yeah I'll Bishop d6 wins more than the
poem yeah
Bishop d6 was the was the knockout
yeah Bishop takes d4 C takes d4 Queen
Dixie six rock f7 yeah the white one a
nice one here as well yeah this one
wasn't so special
huh compared to the other ones alright
let's look at a game lasker against
Bauer we'll do it in like chronological
order now like in terms of years okay
this one is a pretty famous game
actually last Corrigan's power f45 III
Knight of 6 b3 e 6 this should be too
I wouldn't by the way I like to play
simple similar structures and blitz
games I win a lot of games and blitz
games in some similar attacks so it's a
very interesting setup I play English
defense as black and sometimes I get
this structure from the black side so
white finds a very interesting regular
pink Knight c3 92-93
and now black made a mistake Knights xh5
so now question is how should white take
advantage yeah
Oh
yeah [ __ ] takes h7 double bishop
sacrifice very good double bishop suck
King takes takes fish takes g7 and King
takes g7 but is it right away because if
we go yeah I think you have to be a bit
careful if we play right away then yeah
rook g8 no orochi yeah maybe yeah and we
can try to give up this the stroke and
still we have two pieces so maybe not
completely is loo inning so that's why
queen g4 first because there's no king
of six anyway because of Queen g5 and
then we go there and actually
interestingly enough this whole
combination might have not been that all
that effective unless white would have
had this soon and so this little nuance
in the end was actually very important
otherwise materially would be kind of
close like if white does not have that
idea then it's not so clear but there is
this idea so that's the point
yeah so anyway
the rest of the game was pretty simple
yeah yeah yeah there's nothing in the
other side yeah okay next game in
chronological order is nimzowitsch
against the a la peon well actually
there's also stained it's super totally
asain in snooker thought yes we forgot
about that one stain it's super thought
so
if 45 93 96 F 4 takes and NZ 4 ok so
this is called actually stain its gambit
the game was quite sharp here d5
black goes for some sharpness right away
king of tool now the funny thing is this
there was a game stainless against
Mackenzie or three years ago which ended
like this
king of three Queen h4 threatening here
King back and queen e7 and king of three
draw so even from an interesting opening
like that you can still sometimes get
draws so king of two Queen h4 g3 takes
King g2 and now black to kanji for ya
there is also Bishop d6 which was very
very interesting good idea being up to
this you can take and then there's some
problems on de attack on the king
so night 64 was played H takes g3 Queen
g4 Queen e1 Bishop e7 uh here rock h4
was pretty good night 62 will not it's
not so easily but eventually Queen e5
Queen g6 it will be one and then there's
still some difficulties although
actually I mean that's what's Dana says
but in fact it was not so clear so rock
edge for was maybe nothing so special so
Bishop d3 was pretty good I mean just
taking away 962 Queen g6 905 night of 3
Bishop here Bishop there f6 94 night g
h6
and [ __ ] takes h6 Yan I h6 was a
mistake
that was a blunder because after this
this this you know you lose the Queen
and that's how one of the games ended
that was a World Championship match
you know so as you could see though this
style you know confuses opponents can
even confuse world champions sometimes
as you could see all right that was
another interesting game okay now let's
take a look at the game nimzowitsch
against elephant from 1914 okay so just
a casual tournament e4e 6d 45 Knight c3
Knight of 6 eg and then elephant took
Knight 65 which is probably a mistake
earlier in the earlier lecture I showed
you one of Alekhine's games which alkyne
one up to 94 white played Knight of 3
which is also very playable move c5 so
opening up the center even though he's
behind on development probably not the
best idea
Knight 65 Queen text e5 Bishop e3
threatening to win the poem c5 CD night
64 a6 so the idea is preventing 95-foot
it's too slow black is really falling
behind on development here and that's
why he's getting really punished so
Bishop e2 Queen takes here
Bishop f3 again taking on g2 in such a
position is very dangerous because again
we're behind in development
it looks like it's safe but it is in
fact not safe so Queen g6 Queen d2 e 5
alright how should white continue his
initiative in this position
gasps linglong very good
who cares about that piece when you have
such a lead in development right the
most important is just to continue going
with the attack
no retreating eat a exhibition takes 96
all right a white to play and come you
know complete the the triumph triumph
instruct strategy
Rock where AG 1 or e 1 then I'll play
there should be six or maybe even
yeah let's play here
yeah but okay it's not not just not so
forced right I'll go but should be seven
I mean you might still have a very
promising attack but you know here we're
looking for something even I mean again
if you don't see a force wind okay then
you go for a lot move like that but
first we want to see in a position like
that like when Black has only one piece
developed and we have all pieces
developed and black Kings in the center
we want to look for force to win and
sometimes there might be one Ashish what
do you think
um Bishop g7
yeah I mean that might also work maybe
that also is winning well [ __ ] takes c6
is the idea yes so if you take then Bush
takes c6 ya know that wins but I think I
think the move you played is even you
know more finishing off f6 where did you
want to play Bishop TC 6 I think I can
do Queen takes c6 maybe yeah I mean I
guess you yeah but how do you exactly I
mean maybe you can still play Bishop f6
here it's still what I think Bishop f6
right away is cleaner I mean maybe I can
do this okay then you go here right
Queen takes rook e1 yeah I mean oh maybe
there should be six Queen d7 so yeah
this move water might also win which
takes c6 first well actually that's
let's let's see if it does win because
it looks like it does but yeah probably
flower probably does yes Queen takes c6
Bishop f6 alene oh it doesn't well it's
not it's not quite the same because
after this there's fish of d6 now that's
the big difference there's a this
interposition move where you can give
back some of the material and it's not
so winning I mean you can still go
Bishop takes g7 but then I can play here
and give up the room can still continue
playing I mean white is completely
winning now but it's still a game so
same thing after Bush takes g7 I could
just you know give up the rook I mean
okay it's a winning position but not
forced win and by the way you have to be
careful of Bishop h6 soap but I guess
you can start with this or something
basically yeah you're still winning with
[ __ ] takes g7 but Bishop f6 is just to
knock out its total knockout because
this foul by Quincy eight is a threat
Quincy eight right away is also a threat
so what should blog do I mean he has to
take the bishop there's nothing else
and let's say if you take if you go here
for example there's takes you know this
you quindi ate this you go like that
well it's mate I mean it's yeah Allah
that - I mean
yeah so queen of six rookie one yeah and
so there should be six Queen d7 and if
the ship is seven takes king of eight
and now what yeah
yuh-huhhh
got very good
yeah well anyway so that's that that was
that Bishop f6 was that key idea but
again move water is important because if
we do it like this then there is this
defense so that's why it's important to
start with this so precision is always
important when we calculate even if
we're winning it's still important to to
be quite precise
all right I'll let's do one more kappa
blanka Spielman let's uh still close
nuts the Romantic period so Capablanca
was white d4 d5 Knight f3 6c 497 and
also we've looked at only four games
today but this is gonna be a d4 game
which also and here white went for the
system CD d Qin a for trying to exchange
the bishop
so white puts the bishop on c2 to a good
square
rocky one now he's preparing for efore
okay what should white do in this
position
yes that's what he did yeah just take
the pawn give up this bishop and then
take this and then you're going to get
three pawns and the point being if rook
a7 how would white win here Eddie
yeah sheesh
yeah yeah because you're gonna get a new
queen here so you will win a rook so
that's why he had to play rugby eight
but then B takes a six and now white
will have three pawns including one very
strong passer and white is completely
winning a very nice combination rugby
five Queen c7 might be six seven bishop
h3 and he just played rugby one you know
exchanging blacks best piece in the
position the rookin be five blocks best
defense roped x b b1 looked xb1 f5
bishop f3 f4 e 2x of four and black
resigned
black is left with nothing zilch nada
sorry I press the wrong thing
sorry if you uh yeah well I mean um um
yeah yeah I'll hear anything right Queen
you can yes so stick check too many idea
side from b8 so point XD for just too
many ideas Adi
yeah sure yes
yeah one second was it here or no yes
yeah O'Quinn takes a five year up takes
a 500 blue k7r okay seven this one right
okay oh but the Queen Queen's hanging oh
oh I see what you're saying yeah um yeah
maybe it's a good good point
okay well the thing is I still think
white is better rook takes a six so then
white will have materially we have two
pieces for a rook but I mean my pawn is
on a seven I'll have three points one
two three four five six seven one two
three four so I have three pawns and the
rook for two pieces so material I'm I'm
up
plus I have a very powerful porn I'll
play three four so yes you're right I
mean that slime definitely exists and
you're not losing right away but I mean
it will be lost like how would you
continue in this position I'm gonna go a
three
yeah Bishop a8 I'll play like rugby 1
then I'll probably play rugby 6 and then
I will play rook b8 you know if you go
here I'm still going rugby 8 so there
are just too many ideas I mean even if I
don't have anything immediate I'm still
up material and doing very well yeah
mm-hmm
which whatever be six
yeah
yes
yeah exactly yeah that's the point but I
can I I mean I can also do this and then
I can give check and then I can play
that okay you can defend but I mean but
the point is that there already many
ways for whites to be much better the
point the point is when you're going for
a line like this right when you're when
you're seeing this once you see this
you're not really worried about the bit
should be seven sure it might be a
defense but if this is the best he's
gotten then you know you're doing very
well right because the very minimum you
got three points plus like one beast
four nine eight seven and two good rooks
and open files for his knight and Bishop
which are not very coordinated so
materially you're better positionally
you're better I mean all the factors are
still in your favor so even if he has
defenses like that you're not you don't
really have to worry about them but
that's still a very good question I mean
that's still a very good point you made
yeah that this should be seven was a
possible defense but it doesn't really
save the game of course but yeah good
good point that's that was good alert
addy good job
all right um so I'll show you one more
quick game and then we'll that will do
it for for today I'll show you a game
another famous game
Petrosyan against bachman so this was a
very slow positional game and even that
turned into a very nice fireworks so let
this is a good game to finish on good
note that even a quiet little schematic
opening can turn into fireworks this is
what we call Kings Indian attack
yeah here black played d6 so maybe b6
was more precise but d6 looks ok ok so
now white wants to go 94 tempo and on
the Queen and now white played Knight B
3 interesting move to try to attack the
porn gained a tempo and preparing for
Bishop f4 black played 94 also mistake I
mean again same mistake as this guy
against Allah Reza was making right -
those of you [ __ ] world my viewers
moving the same pieces twice he should
at least go here instead moving the same
piece twice before Queen has to already
go to a slightly awkward Square and now
95 preparing Knight c4 and you can
already see how black is very cramped
here very cramped night 6 b3 and here he
doesn't even capture back
he plays first night c4 and this is a
very subtle move based on the fact that
after a be 95 94 there is the move Queen
c6 and black is kind of keeping control
over the game so that's why he played
Knight c4 first and white is just now
almost winning because now if black
plays Queen d8 then we go a B then we go
there and we prepared ok 5 and this pawn
will probably just fall somehow so black
played Queen B 5 8 XV 3 now this rook a5
is a threat so black had to play another
move a5 which is a little bit wasteful
Bishop d6 Bishop f6 and now here comes
the Queen and so that's a queen of three
King g7 rookie for Ruby g8
and now white to play how should white
continue here
you've seen this
okay oh I see
one idea of looking at
Bishop takes p7
mm-hmm Fish Lake c7 [ __ ] take c7
ar-raqqa fate
yeah even have six writers like too many
options so yeah it's certainly a
certainly a possibility but we can
quickly see that it's not gonna be
anything so special
all right Ashish what is it
mm-hmm kingi five mr. g7 very good
that's the key quiet move taking away
the escape square and the black is just
getting made it
remember that Bishop g4 early on from
the viewers choice you know where took
away some escape squares same thing here
you know whenever we're attacking we
always have to look at exit squares I've
listened to enough Larry Christianson
videos when I was younger
and ICC and he always takes talks about
and he is like one of the best attacking
players of all time in the United States
he always talks about taking away the
exit squares and here black the black
king is doomed and black just resigned
there is no way to defend against the
mating attack and with that with this
beautiful game which started from a very
innocent little opening you know even
from like like this you can still win a
nice miniature game if you if your
opponent starts violating some
principles so I hope you guys enjoyed it
and till till next time this is
Grandmaster
Alexandra Linderman
[Music]
you